عمليه تفكيك بدات بها روسيا في اغسطس
الماضي لمنظومه اس 3 في سوريا التقطتها
الاقمار الصناعيه لتعلن وكاله ايميجسات
انترناشونال الاسرائيليه انا روسيا تنقل
بطاريه المنظومه الى البحر الاسود وتدور
التوقعات حول نقل المنظومه بالكامل
لاستخدامها في الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
توقعاتهم تصيب على ما يبدوه اليوم تطلب
روسيا من اسرائيل عدم عرقلت نقلها لمنظمات
الدفاع الجوي من قواعدها العسكريه في
سوريا الى اوكرانيا
مع المعلومات الاستخباراتيه الغربيه حول
انخفاض مخزون روسيا من الاسلحه بعيده
المدى منها على وجه الخصوص مخمنه انها لا
تكفي الا لشهر واحد اخر تصريحات الغرب
كانت من قبل وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه
والتي بينت ان الطلعات الجويه الروسيه في
اوكرانيا فضت بعد معلومات تفيد بان اللجوء
روسيا للمسيرات الايرانيه هو نتيجه العوز
في الصواريخ البالستيه الروسيه
القتال في اوكرانيا يسير بوتيره منخفضه
ويشير الى ان القوات الاوكرانيه قد تكون
لها افاق اكثر اشراقه في الاشهر المقبله
ليست منظومه اس 3 فقط التي يتم سحبها من
سوريا مصادر اكدت للعربيه ان الوجود
الروسيه في المناطق الداخليه والجنوبيه قد
قل واصبح مختصرا على بعض الضباط الذين
يقومون بالاشراف على العمليات عدا عن
انخفاض وتيره الطلعات الجويه الروسيه في
اشاره الى السحب سلاح الجو الروسي من
سوريا
روسيا التي تعتبر من اكبر الموردين للمواد
الخام لتصنيع السلاح بعد التلجئ الى
صواريخ كوريا الشماليه ومسيرات ايران لا
بل لاساليب اخرى كالهجمات السوبرانيه على
البناء التحتيه الاوكرانيه التي لا يقل
تاثيرها عن الضربات الماديه بحسب مصادر
الغربيه الى عمر العربيه